look they're not all gonna be winners
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so I did my most anticipated
movies of 2019 I got to do the flip side
I got to talk about the movies coming
out and this year that I'm pretty sure
gonna suck at least in terms of what I
like now I want to be very clear about a
couple things before I get into these
movies the first is I don't want any of
these to stink I just believe that they
will so that's the first thing I'm not
actively rooting against any of these
I just don't think they'll be good um
and if they are good that'll be an
awesome surprise I don't think they will
be though and secondly when I say I
believe these will suck I mean they will
suck to my tastes and my preferences and
what I like if the reasons that I cite
for why I think this thing is gonna
stink don't apply to you you are not
under any obligation to think these are
gonna stink these are this is my gauge
of my own enjoyment and I don't think
I've got to enjoy any of these so I
don't have a full 10 for this list um
partially because I wanted to be fair
and try and limit it to stuff that I I
felt really solid and could give reasons
because like there were films coming out
in the latter half of the year that like
we don't know anything about yet that I
could ray along if I was being
mean-spirited and also there are films
that like just flat out are made for me
like there's a there's plenty of
romantic comedies or you know gory
horror movies or things that like I
don't especially enjoy those kinds of
things in the first place why would I
rag on it I don't have a dog in that
race so I'm not dealing with any of that
this is movies that theoretically should
appeal to me given my fandoms and my
interest but I still think are gonna
suck so um I'm gonna do this listen the
same way I did my most anticipated which
is I'm not ranking them but I'm gonna do
them in the order of release starting
with what's coming out first or what's
coming out latest in the year so first
up Jacob's Ladder
yeah did you know there's a Jacob
Jacob's Ladder remake it's coming out in
February
supposedly I couldn't find a trailer
it's coming supposed to come out next
month but I couldn't find the trailer
like it has been finished for over a
year
like this entire thing stinks of a
studio under contract to release it
theatrically but is doing it for no
reason other than to fill that
contractual obligation there's been zero
promotion zero anything to judge this on
and this close to the supposed of at
least eight holy cow oh man I mean aside
from the fact that like why would you
try and remake Jacob's Ladder I mean
talk about it
talk about a product of its time in
terms of the the the feel and the vibe
and also you know that's sort of weird
twisty like we twist movies don't work
well as remakes like it is a bad idea in
the first place and then everything sets
off a red flag about this next up one
that I know other people are looking
forward to and if you are fine and if
you like it even better I'm not gonna
watch it and I think it'll suck and
that's Dumbo I've got my issues with the
Disney live-action remakes of their
animated films in the first place I've
talked about it before I won't bring
that end of it up again but I look at
this one particularly and I'm like Dumbo
is one of the shortest things they made
how painful is the padding gonna be and
then I see the trailer and I go oh
they're gonna beef up the humans story
they're gonna Pat it out by the same
philosophy of how they padded out the
Transformers and the the more recent
Ninja Turtles movies to not make it
actually about the characters in the
title or all their to see make it about
their human friends who nobody gives a
crap about and can we just I'm not gonna
say don't have Tim Burton direct stuff
anymore but can we stop having him
direct remakes and like really specific
adaptations of like
get the guy on some original stuff again
or stuff that isn't like tied to a
specific
existing vision because all you're doing
is Tim Burton enough an existing thing
and like no that just he values
everything involved all right next up a
movie he's had made my list last year
but didn't come out because it got
bumped Dark Phoenix boy oh boy
yes cuz I'm sure being delayed a year a
massively reshot suddenly means it's
gotta be great no it's not I like I for
purely academic purposes I would be
really curious to see the cut that was
going to be released last year and
compared to the one that's gonna be
coming out this year if only to find out
the different ways in which they suck
cuz I expect they both suck I'm pretty
sure that the reshoots were only done in
order to make it a firm ending for the
ex for the Fox x-men films so that that
is can that book is considered close
when did when the merger finally
finishes up and Marvel is allowed to use
the x-men characters themselves again
but I've got an existing video up from
oh my god like a year and a half ago and
explaining why it's gonna suck and I
still stand by every single word of that
so you want details it's right there but
oh man next up after that term eight or
six why is anyone making Terminator
movies I understand that it's still a
brand recognized name but there has
literally never been a good Terminator
movie since 1991 and even that was not
as good as the original yeah you heard
me but it was still at least good and it
expanded things as opposed to trying to
recapture something that came before
which is let every single one of them
has done since then and we've tried
every iteration of this already they
don't work
we tried basically remaking t2 again
with an older version of John
Konnor with the rise of the machines
that didn't work
we tried finally showing the the future
war between humanity and the machines
with what revelation redemption Rigo
whoever whatever the heck the subtitle
wasn't one the one with Christian Bale
that didn't work we tried doing
alternate timeline and basically
completely messing with time-travel to
be able to fracture off and do a whole
other thing with Genesis that didn't
work when do we stop
when can you when whoever owns the
property when can you admit defeat these
don't work and I know James cameras
actually involves someone in this one
I don't care there's nothing left to be
squeezed out of this property that's of
any value who please just
up next up this one a hurt to put on
this list because this was also on my
list last year but not my movies that I
thought was gonna suck this was on my
most anticipated movies list of last
year and now I can't help but expect it
to suck given what's gone on that's New
Mutants yeah remember that the horror
looking x-men related film that a
trailer dropped out of nowhere we all
were kind of like whoa this is different
and cool and then they push the movie
out of here and of course I'm putting it
on this list assuming it even gets
released like it really is feeling like
if Dark Phoenix bombs hard enough that
they'll just shelve this I hope it's
good but a movie getting delayed a year
is not something that is gonna engender
a lot of hope in me and I don't know as
much about the details of the reshoots
on this as I do would say dark Phoenix
but like that doesn't bode well either
because the word as we understand it
since that trailer came out was that the
trailer was something that the trailer
company put together based off the
footage they had acts
- and was not actually representative of
the finished film and that a part of the
reach again this is my understanding if
I'm wrong somebody correct me but then
the reshoots of the film were done to
make the film more in line with the
trailer that was already released and
why does this sound so familiar
oh right Suicide Squad just move on okay
this next one is the one that I am
pretty sure I'm gonna get the harshest
pushback on and I'm really gonna have to
explain my own reasonings for this it
chapter two there's a two factor
contribution for why this is on my list
the first is I didn't really like it
that much I seem to be the only person
on the planet who didn't really like it
as much I didn't hate it to be clear I
mean it didn't you know we didn't even
come close to getting like a
dishonorable mention worst movies all
that year or anything but I just didn't
care for it
I mean it was okay I thought it was kind
of lazy in a lot of ways it was not as
inventive as I wanted to be the child
actors were great like all props to that
but it just it didn't work for me and
the reason that this the follow up is on
this list is because everyone who I know
who knows the book really well and knows
the source material is very open about
the fact that all of the best stuff from
the book is what they used in the first
movie all the stuff with the kids as
adults all the additional material
they're gonna be pulling from to make
the second movie out of is the weaker
material like I don't know anyone who
doesn't feel that way who is familiar
with the original book so when you are
doing a sequel to a movie that I was
only kind of met on and you're making it
out of the material that's not as good
and inherently there's going to be very
very little of the one major thing that
I like from the first one which is the
kids I know they're bringing them back a
little bit but like they can't be the
main focus because we've got the adults
now
yeah I don't see any reason that I'm
gonna like this at all
next up another one that kind of hurts
to put on here and but I'm still ticked
and I'm putting it on here anyway
Kingsman three and I know it's a pretty
cool so you know it won't involve the
any of the actors or the storylines that
have been done up to this point but I I
really hated the Golden Circle the
second Kingsman movie it would it it is
up there with Ghostbusters two and men
in black 2 as I honestly think one of
the worst sequels made I really hated it
and that's not to say there's absolutely
nothing good in it there are good
moments they're good bits they're good
performances but as a film as a whole
I really couldn't stand it I might have
not put this on the list I might have
given it a pass for benefit of the doubt
if Matthew Vaughn wasn't directing it
because I feel that Kingsman the Golden
Circle is the very first legitimately
not good movie Matthew Vaughn has ever
directed and it doesn't make me want to
see him go back to that well I would
rather that he produced it and they got
director you know somebody else to come
in and he and you know Vaughn could
guide it but like go off and do
something else dude you nosedived on
this property let somebody else do it so
yeah I love the original Kingsman I'm
not looking forward to this and finally
shaft or possibly son of shaft as it's
probably gonna be known in some
territories yeah did you know that this
was happening so it's not a it's not
another attempt to remake the 70s class
this blaxploitation classic shaft it is
an attempt to continue it which
technically the 2001 with Samuel Jackson
was to so actually it shouldn't even be
some shaft it should be son of nephew of
shaft because they are bringing back
Richard Roundtree and
Jackson as original and updated chef and
now we have an addition to that the guy
who played the Will Smith's kid in the
last and the second independent state I
don't know the guys work I don't want to
judge him too harshly but I can't help
but feel that he's suffering from that
boy studios and ages thought you were
gonna be a big thing you're not kind of
a similar thing that Sam Warrington and
enjoy Courtney went through but yeah why
wha-hey exists uh
and nothing against honestly either
version of shaft they both had there was
both some fun to be had but like taking
it I do not gonna be able to take it
seriously and they I mean they could try
and parody it a bit more but like
there's too many good things out there
that parody this kind of thing already
or have done in the last few years and
yeah I just this this is one of those
cases of like somebody had the property
rights and they wanted to do something
with it
this this was the best they had and
that's terrifying that's my list eight
movies coming out in 2019 that I think
are going to suck what movies coming out
do you think are not going to be very
good at all whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
you can do because there's buns and
there's legs and there's all sorts of
stuff that you can click down there this
link to my patreon if you want to
support me and this kind of content but
there's other links as well check them
out if you want if you don't want to
that it's okay cuz at the end of the day
you're the council and I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]